hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his book a
theory of Justice John Rawls will
identify two principles of justice that
he takes to be at the core of the theory
which he is offering as the correct one
and as a guide not just for social and
political theory but also in some other
respects for for ethics more broadly
speaking and he sets things up in such a
way that we're going to arrive at these
principles by engaging in a sort of
thought experiment or hypothetical
situation the original position or
initial situation he calls it and and
it's associated with this term the veil
of ignorance and the basic idea is that
we're deciding on fundamental principles
that are going to govern the way society
works and we're going to come to some
sort of agreement together on them
deliberatively rationally without
knowing where we would end up in that
society without knowing who we are going
to be and Rawls thinks that if we enter
into those sort of conditions we carry
out this reasoning process
in that way we're going to arrive
inevitably at two really fundamental
basic principles which then he
articulates one is as he's going to call
it early on equality and assignment of
basic rights and duties and he'll flesh
that out a little bit more and then the
second is that inequalities are only
just if they result in compensating
benefits for all not for the aggregate
of society so he was avoiding any sort
of utilitarianism here as a matter of
fact he explicitly rejects
utilitarianism he's saying that
inequalities if they're going to be just
if they're going to be right if they're
going to be acceptable have to provide
benefits for everybody in that society
so a little bit later in the the work in
Chapter eleven he titles that two
principles of justice and he he says I'm
going to state in a provisional form
these two principles that I believe
would be agreed to in the original
position and he tells us that the
formulation of these is tentative so
he's going to refine them a little bit
more in the course of the book but these
are in fact the articulations that most
people who are working off of Rawls take
to be essentially the the way to
understand these so he says here's the
way we can we can state these two
principles the first he says each person
is to have an equal right to the most
extensive scheme of equal basic
liberties compatible with a similar
scheme of liberties for others so that
requires a little bit of unpacking but
it's a fairly succinct formulation the
second he says and this one has two
different parts to it the second is that
social and economic inequalities are to
be arranged so that they are both
there's the two conditions reasonably
expected to be to everyone's advantage
and to be at-at attached to positions
and offices open to all so let's look at
these initially and then we'll look at
what Rawls actually has to say first
each person is to have an equal right to
the most extensive scheme of equal basic
liberties compatible with a similar
scheme of liberties for others so
obviously that that last part you can't
have freedom to anything whatsoever like
freedom to imprison your neighbor in the
cellar for 20 years
feeding them on apples and root
vegetables or something like that that's
ridiculous right because you're
violating their freedom in that case and
this is where we get into you know once
we get away from the general principles
when we get into the nitty-gritty it
gets quite complex right I want to
exercise my freedom to listen to my
music at 3 o'clock in the morning and I
live on a 10 acre plot my neighbors are
kind of far away how loud can I have it
cranked up you know we get into these
sort of questions Rawls isn't concerned
at this point in worrying about that but
he knows that those those situations are
going to arise sooner or later
now equal right an equal right so not
you know one person gets more than
others to the most extensive scheme the
widest possible scheme of equal basic
liberties we can also call these equal
rights so this is going to be pretty
pretty expansive and you might say well
man he sounds like a libertarian as we
see he's actually gonna be opposed to
that sort of view and it's gonna lead
more towards Anna Galit arianism of
sorts let's look at the second one now
so like we pointed out it's got two
different parts to it and it says that
there there can be social and economic
inequalities so you know it seems like
there's there's going to be some tension
here with the first but we're gonna see
how these are reconciled social and
economic inequalities can exist but they
have to be of such a nature
so that they're meeting these two
conditions now that would mean society
would have to have some basic rules
governing these things it can't just
well let any qualities grow and do
whatever they're going to do social
Darwinism Rawls would reject that sort
of view right he would say no no we can
have inequalities you can pay doctors
more than you know street sweepers but
you got to have some reasons for it so
one of the reasons is it's reasonably
expected to be to everyone's advantage
now notice he doesn't say we know with a
hundred percent certainty no reasonably
expected reasonable people can get
together and say you know if we don't
pay doctors better there may be a few
people who do it as a hobby or because
they're you know drawn to that
profession but we're probably going to
have a crisis with medicine so it would
be - everybody's advantage to actually
have doctors be compensated more highly
maybe not you know astronomically highly
then we start getting into the specifics
right now notice the other part and
attach to physicians and offices open to
all there has to be equal access equal
opportunity if we're going to have
inequalities they have to be attached to
things that that really anybody within
the society if they choose to say
undergo the training or the licensing or
whatever it's going to be that they
could have access to it they aren't just
simply being excluded so let's now look
at how Rawls goes a little bit into
detail about this and talking about the
first principle he says that the basic
liberties can be given by a list of
these sorts of liberties these include
political Liberty their right to vote
and hold public office freedom of speech
and assembly liberty of conscience that
is to say no to things or to do things
because
you have formulated you know that it's
the right thing to do
freedom of thought freedom of the person
he says which includes freedom from
psychological oppression maybe say
bullying or harassment and physical
assault and dismemberment the right to
hold personal property and freedom from
arbitrary arrest and seizure he says all
these liberties are to be equal by the
first principle if you give them to one
person you got to give them to everybody
and you've got to observe them equally
so you can't for example say well you
know stop and frisk it really is is okay
to do to people who are poor or people
who have dark skin or people who look
like they might be coming from the
Middle East or or or or right all these
sort of provisos if you're gonna do stop
and frisk you gotta apply it to
everybody equally because you're
infringing on a you know some basic
liberties freedom of arbitrary arrests
and seizure
you know perhaps freedom of thought
depending on what they're expressing
with what they're wearing and there's
all sorts of things here probably a stop
and frisk policy is not gonna pass
rauzein rules but there's all sorts of
other things that we can think about so
you know holding personal property right
should this be allowed yes Rawls says of
course doesn't mean that I can do
anything whatsoever I want with my
property because that could infringe on
the liberties of others what about the
second one he says the second principle
applies to the distribution of income
and wealth and to the design of
organizations that make use of
differences in authority and
responsibility so now we're getting to
two things that are quite important he
says well the distribution of wealth and
income need not be equal it must be -
everybody's Advaita
that's a very telling point if you want
to have a just society you can certainly
have inequalities but those inequalities
must work out to the advantage of
everybody it's hard to see how in
contemporary modern society the massive
inequalities that we have actually work
out well for say the homeless population
or the working poor or even you know the
middle class whatever that happens to be
they seem to work out quite well for
others and they would fail on Rawls's
account in that case you could say well
you know we need to encourage job
creation and innovation and bringing
products to market and all that ok if
it's really to the advantage of
everybody of everybody not just
shareholders not just those who like
getting the newest thing but to
everybody you can make a case for that
then you can have those inequalities but
those still have to be open to anybody
say then in that case entering the
market right positions he says of
authority and responsibility must be
accessible to all one applies the second
principle by holding positions open and
then subject to this constraint arranges
social and economic inequality so that
everybody benefits now notice he doesn't
just say economic inequalities he's also
saying social inequalities how we treat
people how we regard people this is a
very important we want to be able to
acknowledge the dignity of other human
beings now he's going to go on and say
that there's a priority between these
two the first takes priority over the
second and again when you when you hear
that you might say ah yeah he he sounds
like a libertarian in fact again it's
it's not that case as he goes on he says
that infringement of the basic equal
liberties protected by the first
principle cannot be justified or
compensated for by the greater social
and economic advantages these liberties
have a central ray
of application in which they could be
limited and compromised only when they
conflict with other basic liberties so
he says for example liberties not on the
list the right to own certain kinds of
property for example means of production
and freedom of contract is understood by
the doctrine of lezzie fair these are
not basic and are not protected by the
priority of the first principle so he
also says with regard to the second
principle distribution of wealth and
income and positions of authority and
responsibility must be consistent with
both the basic liberties and equality of
opportunity and then he provides us with
a sort of summary of how you can bring
these two together he says all social
values liberty and opportunity income
and wealth and the social basis of
self-respect are to be distributed
equally unless an unequal distribution
of any or all of these values is to
everyone's advantage so again we we see
that he's willing to countenance some
inequality but you've got to be able to
make a case that it is reasonably
expected to be to the advantage of all
not a merely rhetorical case about you
know job creation or it's better to be
paternalistic and not have people you
know thinking for themselves or whatever
you're going to do you you actually have
to be able to make a strong case that
the inequalities are going to be -
everybody's advantage and so these two
principles provide the skeleton of
Rawls's egalitarian conception of
justice this is applicable to any
organization to any institution to any
interaction between people provided
we're thinking things through
and it's definitely intended to provide
overarching rules or a conception of
justice for an entire society now most
societies would fail these these rules
which means that most societies are at
least to some degree
unjust and this would be helpful in
telling us how and why and to what
extent they're unjust and conversely for
following Rawls's theory what we would
need to do in order to move that society
or organization or whatever it's going
to be towards a more just condition so
this is the two principles again right
at the very center of Rawls's conception
of justice derived by considering what
rational people would do within a veil
of ignorance in which they have to work
out rules for everybody not knowing
where they would end up in that society
it would be rational Rawls says to
choose these two different principles
and to enforce them
you